um here's some interesting new polling
data since the draft from the supreme
court
leaked
which revealed to us that unless
something changes roe v wade will be
overturned in the next few weeks since
that leaked support for abortion rights
in most or all cases
has gone up to 60 percent which is the
highest level in two decades according
to a new nbc news poll let's look at
some comments about the polling from
mark murray who's the senior political
editor for nbc news results from the
poll abortion should be
always legal say 37 of americans legal
most of the time say 23 percent of
americans so in total 60 of americans
believe that abortion should be always
or mostly legal the combined 60
is the highest percentage on this
question going all the way back to 2003.
now you might say okay but hold on wait
a second david whoa whoa whoa
the draft opinion from the supreme court
makes it
uh just something states can decide so
the polling doesn't really change
because you could be against roe v wade
but still in favor of the state keeping
abortion legal okay well the draft
opinion would make it legal
for states to make abortion illegal and
that's ultimately the same thing at the
end of the day on the question from the
poll should roe v wade be overturned and
this goes to that
only 30 percent believe that roe v wade
should be overturned that is up from 23
in 2018
but 63 percent nearly two-thirds of the
country believe that roe v wade should
not be overturned that is down slightly
from 2018. now there's another question
here when we think about the political
impact of this forthcoming decision
we've been wondering what will it do to
the midterm elections will it inspire
democrats and people on the left to get
out and vote for democrats by and large
for independent voters we know abortion
is not historically a big voting issue
for independence
but what might it do for voter turnout
for democrats we haven't had any new
polling that i've been able to find on
like a generic congressional ballot for
november since the supreme court
decision leaked it would be very
interesting to look at that data and
hopefully we will have it soon the the
other part of this by the way
when we see 60 of americans believe
abortion should be legal in most or all
cases that 60 percent is not represented
in the senate and as i've told you
before the senate is a fundamentally
anti-democratic body
you can have in the senate because every
state gets two senators
you can have
50 percent of the population
uh i'm sorry you can have 50 of the
senate votes
represented
by those who have only 17 percent of the
population in their states that's
extraordinarily lopsided and
undemocratic and it's considered a
feature
not a bug of the senate by many so we're
going to continue following the numbers
but support for abortions legality up to
record highs
since the leaked supreme court decision
and we'll have more of that polling data
on our instagram you can find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
what if you could get through an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist takes top nonfiction books in
every genre boils them down into a text
or audio explainer that you can consume
in 15 minutes of course blinkist would
never replace reading real books in
their entirety but blinkist lets you
absorb the most important insights from
the non-fiction books you wouldn't
otherwise have time for i have a ton of
different ways i consume information and
blinkist is one of those and it's super
efficient i just used blinkist to listen
to the book toxic positivity
super interesting just about this like
happiness obsessed culture that now we
live in got through it in 15 minutes
with all of the key points blinkist also
takes tons of popular podcasts and
creates a 15-minute explainer for each
episode and blinkist really just
empowers you to grow by discovering new
ideas knowledge that will give you
valuable new perspectives about the
world go to blinkist.com pacman to try
blinkist free for seven days and you'll
get twenty five percent off a premium
subscription that's just six twenty five
a month the link is down below